non leurs vacances confie ce pas
justement le fils de pascal se taisent
qui était non publique par hasard je les
prie dans le public regardez ce qui se
passe qu'est chickens c'est tout ça est
bien le fils de pascal ce texte
maintenant c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
alors pourquoi faire ça tu es content
bouffon ouais j'ai la victime d'où si ça
te va y perdre c'est pourquoi des côtes
avec nous et je le il a l'air tellement
gentille ton fils est sûre je suis sûr
que ça assure qu'il est hyper gentil il
est gentil et puis tu ferais drouin
chiffres puisque tu es content
l'apathique toi toi tu as repris
confiance en toi a repris confiance en
toi tu étais comme ça toi tu as tu étais
tout schuss la taille et verlaine était
dans le mur toi là tu as repris le tir
était tranquille ou batteleku vos gosses
ça va tellement toi quand même isabelle
d'ilebo là je tombe très bien même
vraiment très bien bakel mais bon
comment vous pourriez être jeune arrière
arrière grand mère
[Applaudissements]
ah oui là
tu as quel âge 20 ans arrière seulement
[Applaudissements]